is there a connection to the second law
of Thermodynamics and cellular automata
oh yes those are the things you the
things you've discovered About Cellular
automata yes okay so when I first
started selling Cellular automata my
first papers about them were you know
the first sentence was always about the
second row of thermodynamics it was
always about how does order manage to be
produced even though there's a second
row of thermodynamics which tries to
pull things back into disorder and I
kind of my early understanding of that
had to do with these are intrinsically
irreversible processes in cellular
automata that that form uh kind of
conform orderly structures even from
random initial conditions but then what
I realized this was uh well actually
it's it's one of these things where it
was a discovery that I should have made
earlier but didn't so you know I had
I've been studying solid automata what I
did was the sort of most obvious
computer experiment you just try all the
different rules and see what they do
it's kind of like you know you've
invented a computational telescope you
just point pointed at the most obvious
thing in the sky and they just see
what's there and so I did that and I you
know was making all these pictures of of
how cellular automata work and and I
started these pictures I studied in
great detail There Was You Can number
the rules for cellular automata and one
of them is you know rule 30. so I made a
picture of rule 30 back in 1981 or so
and Rule 30 well it's and at the time I
was just like okay it's another one of
these rules I don't really it happens to
be asymmetric Left Right asymmetric and
it's like let me just consider the case
of the symmetric ones just to keep
things simpler
Etc et cetera et cetera and I just kind
of ignored it yeah and then
sort of in actually in 1984 strangely
enough I I ended up having a an early
laser printer which made very high
resolution pictures and I thought I'm
going to print out an interesting you
know I want to make an interesting
picture let me take this rule 30 thing
and just make a high resolution picture
of it I did and it's it has this very
remarkable property that's rule is very
simple you started off just from one
black cell at the top and it makes this
kind of triangular pattern but if you
look inside this pattern it looks really
random there's you know you look at the
center column of cells and you know I
studied that in great detail and it's so
far as one can tell it's completely
random and it's kind of a little bit
like digits of pi once you you know you
know the rule for generating the digit
Supply but once you've generated them
you know 3.14159 Etc they seem
completely random and in fact I put up
this prize back in what was it 2019 or
something for prove anything about the
sequence basically has anyone been able
to do anything on that uh people have
sent me some things but it's you know I
don't know how these problems are I mean
I was kind of spoiled because I 2007 I
put up a prize for uh determining
whether a particular turing machine that
I thought was the simplest candidate for
being Universal turing machine determine
whether it is or isn't a universal
turing machine and somebody did a really
good job of of winning that prize and
proving that it was a universal turing
machine in about six months and so I you
know I didn't know whether that would be
one of these problems that was out there
for hundreds of years or whether in this
particular case young chap called Alex
Smith
um you know nailed it in six months and
so with this little 30 collection I
don't really know whether these are
things that are 100 years away from
being able to to get or whether
somebody's going to come and do
something very clever it's such a means
like from our Last Theorem essentially a
rule 30 is such a simple formulation it
feels like anyone can look at it and
understand it yeah and feel like it's
within grasp
to be able to predict something to do to
direct some kind of law
right it allows you to predict something
about this middle column of rule 30.
right but you know this is yeah you
can't yeah right this is the intuitional
surprise of computational irreducibility
and so on that even though the rules are
simple you can't tell what's going to
happen and you can't prove things about
it and I think so so anyway the the the
the thing uh I I still started in 1984
or so I started realizing there's this
phenomenon that you can have very simple
rules they produce apparently random
Behavior okay so that's a little bit
like the second orthogonomics because
it's like you have this simple initial
condition you can you know readily see
that it's very you know you can describe
it very easily and yet it makes this
thing that seems to be random now turns
out
thus some technical detail about the
secular thermodynamics and about the
idea of reversibility when you have a if
you have kind of a a a movie of two you
know billiard balls colliding and you
see them Collide and they bounce off and
you run that movie In Reverse you can't
tell which way was the forward direction
of time and which way was the backward
direction of time when you're just
looking at individual billiard Balls by
the time you've got a whole collection
of them you know a million of them or
something then it turns out to be the
case and this is the the sort of the The
Mystery of the second law that the
orderly thing you start with the orderly
thing and it becomes disordered and
that's the forward Direction in time and
the other way around of it starts to
sorted and becomes ordered you just
don't see that in the world
now in principle if you you know if you
sort of traced the detailed motions of
all those molecules backwards you would
be able to it it will it will the
reverse of time makes you know as you as
you go forwards in time order goes to
disorder as you go backwards in time
order goes to disorder perfectly so yes
right so the the mystery is why is it
the case that one version of the mystery
is why is it the case that you never see
something which happens to be just the
kind of disorder that you would need to
somehow evolve to order why does that
not happen why do you always just see
order goes to disorder not the other way
around
so the thing that I I kind of realized I
started realizing in the 1980s is kind
of like it's a bit like cryptography
it's kind of like you start off from
this this key that's pretty simple and
then you kind of run it and you can get
this you know complicated random mess
and uh the thing that that um
well I sort of started realizing back
then was that the second law is kind of
a a story of computational reducibility
it's a story of you know what seems you
know what what we can describe easily at
the beginning we can only describe with
a lot of computational effort at the end
okay so now we come many many years
later and um uh I was trying to sort of
uh well having done this big project to
understand fundamental physics I
realized that sort of a key aspect of
that is understanding what observers are
like
and then I realized that the second
orthodynamics is the same story as a
bunch of these other cases
um it is a story of a a computationally
bounded Observer trying to observe a
computationally irreducible system so
it's a story of you know underneath the
molecules are bouncing around they're
bouncing around in this completely uh
determined way determined by rules but
the point is that that we as
computationally bounded observers can't
tell that there were these sort of
simple underlying rules to us it just
looks random and when it comes to this
question about can you prepare the
initial state so that
um you know the disordered thing is you
know how exactly the right disorder to
make something orderly a computationally
bounded Observer cannot do that we'd
have to have done all of this sort of
irreducible computation to work out very
precisely why what this disordered State
what the exact rate disordered state is
so that we would get this ordered thing
produced from it what does it mean to be
computationally bounded Observer
so observing a computational reducible
system so the computationally bounded is
there something formal you can say there
right so it means
okay you can you can talk about Turing
machines you can talk about
computational uh complexity Theory and
uh you know uh polynomial time
computation and things like this there
are a variety of ways to make something
more precise but I think it's more
useful the intuitive version of it is
more useful yeah which is basically just
to say that you know how much
computation are you going to do to try
and work out what's going on and the
answer is you're not allowed to do a lot
of we're not able to do a lot of
computation when we you know we've got
you know in this room there will be a
trillion trillion trillion molecules a
little bit less it's a big room
right and uh you know
at every moment you know that every
microsecond or something these molecules
molecules are colliding and that's a lot
of computation that's getting done and
the question is in our brains we do a
lot less computation every second than
the computation done by all those
molecules if there is computational
irreducibility we can't work out in
detail what all those molecules are
going to do what we can do is only a
much smaller amount of computation and
so the the second law of Thermodynamics
is this kind of interplay between the
underlying computational irreducibility
and the fact that we as preparers of
initial States or as measures of what
happens are you know are not capable of
doing that much computation so to us
another big formulation of the second
order of thermodynamics is this idea of
the law of entropy increase
the characteristic that this universe
the entropy sees to be always increasing